now what was the point of
differentiating we were looking
for turning points so what i'm going to
say is turning points
may exist because we're maximizing here
turning points may exist
when our derivative is zero
so i'm getting f dash of theta equals
zero so that's everything you can see
here
i want that to equal zero of course
that's not a guarantee of turning
points we might just get stationary
points a horizontal point of inflection
but we'll have to deal with that problem
a bit later on
how do we find when this thing is equal
to zero well the most obvious thing that
i can see is that i can
factorize out this two sine theta on the
numerators of both fractions so if i do
that
and write that 2 sine theta out the
front
what that leaves me with is an enormous
fraction which is going to have let's
let's do it like this
i've factorized out that 2 sine theta so
i end up with
these having the ones on the numerators
left
and i'm multiplying through by that
entire thing that's equal to 0.
so at what point does this equal 0 well
there are two ways
to solve this because you have two
factors right so number one i can think
about
or how do i solve for this being equal
to zero
well i get sine theta equals zero
um how do i solve that within the given
domain there's three intercepts
with the real or the theta axis i should
say
they happen at zero pi and two pi just
think about your sine function which
waves up and down like so
i do notice that even though i've got
three solutions here thinking back to
the complex plane
an argument of 0 and argument 2 pi are
going to give you exactly the same
thing so this is really 0 or
pi right i'll come back to that let's
hit pause on that for a moment
i now want to think about this other
factor here i chose the wrong thing
this other factor over here how do i
solve for this
well this is going to be this whole
awkward thing here is going to be zero
if these two fractions are
equal to each other right if i had say
like a half minus a half
then this entire awkward factor would
equal 0. so in order to have
these two fractions being equal well the
numerators are always
already the same so i just need to focus
on the denominators
these two fractions will be the same if
their denominators are the same
in other words what i want is for this
denominator to equal this denominator so
let's have a look at what i get
if i didn't mean to bring that with me
uh let's see what happens if i try and
solve for these two things
being equal to each other so you know
that'll do me all right the first thing
i notice is that well the square roots
of two things will be equal if the two
things underneath the square roots are
equal
so therefore i can just say it's 5 minus
cos theta equals 5
plus 4 cos theta i can add 4 cos theta
to both sides which would give me 8 cos
theta over here on the right hand side
and no cos theta is on the left
and then i can subtract 5 from both
sides which gives me 0.
so what i'm solving here is for cos
theta being equal to 0
because that 8 doesn't really make a
difference thinking about what the cos
function does that starts at the top
and winds down to give you that sort of
valley shape so the two solutions you're
going to get are pi on 2
or 3 pi on 2. so at this point here
what do you do well if you wanted to
find a maximum
and you really really wanted to hurt
yourself then what you do is say
oh i need to differentiate again to find
the
second derivative or i need to test this
first derivative
um on either side i need to do a
neighborhood test for all of my
potential
values but i hope you are looking at
this and thinking
i definitely do not want to do a second
derivative test because that looks
terrible to differentiate again
nor do i really want to do a
neighborhood test because look at how
many values i have to test back and
forth between and even this derivative
like the first derivative is messy
enough
um to substitute into it's not a nice
neat thing so now even though we were
trying to avoid it we are going to have
to resort back to some geometric
reasoning
in order to make heads or tails of these
many solutions and what we can notice is
that if we go back
to what this graph actually tells us and
how these points relate to each other
we can actually see that even though
there appear to be four stationary
points we can clearly work out
which ones are relevant and in fact that
several of them overlap with each other
um to then determine the solution which
we already saw
um earlier so what i want you to
remember is that we had a look
at how zero and two pi were equivalent
answers and that's because if you have a
look at where
the red and the blue complex numbers are
at the moment
they're currently positioned when theta
equals 0.
and if i go all the way to theta equals
2 pi we've just wound back around this
is the periodicity of the trigonometry
functions
and the exponential form of a complex
number so 0 and 2 pi we've already sort
of eliminated that
but you can actually go one step further
and you can see that for example between
0
and pi only one of these solutions is
relevant let's let's see why
if you have a look at this x equals
let's go back to i'm sorry theta equals
zero situation okay
so you can see that the red magnitude
here is one
and the blue magnitude is three but if
we go over to the
theta equals pi situation this winds us
over
to the other side of each of excuse me
each of the circles
so i'm roughly close enough there now
you can see here even though i have a
completely different
angle theta and i have a completely
different
red and blue points when you add up the
magnitudes to the red and the blue
complex numbers
you get the same result because instead
of we saw this earlier
1 plus 3 i'm getting 3 plus 1. so
therefore i can say
over here that these two results these
two results are actually
equivalent to each other so i just need
to take one of them
like say zero and consider that as the
important one
then i can test out in the same logic if
we have a look at
pi on two and three pi on two let's go
to pi on 2 which we saw earlier
i've gone past there we go roughly you
get the idea
um you have a look at pi on 2 you can
see you've got your red and your blue
that's bothering me now i'm going to try
and get that a little more precise
um gone the wrong way ah
the curse of a stubby finger um maybe if
i use my pen that will actually be
better
that'll just have to do so you've got
your blue and your red
magnitude there this is for my theta
equals pi on two situation
if i then go and look at the three pi
and two situation maybe you've already
worked out from our previous
exploration of the different angles as i
go around to three pi on two
you can see you're going to get exactly
the same magnitudes it's just that
they're on the bottom half
of the complex plane not the top half so
you can see there
red plus blue you get the same congruent
right angle triangles that we got before
so clearly i can actually say both of
these angles with regard to our question
our equivalent so you might as well just
consider one of them
pi on two just consider that one and so
we've brought it back down to um
the same situation we were when we were
trying this question without calculus
right we've come back to that point
where
we're comparing let's go back up to it
we're comparing
uh this situation here theta equals zero
we've got a length there one plus three
gives you four
three plus one also gives you four
versus this situation here where we have
the um
the two complex numbers at the top or
the bottom it's equivalent
and we get our two root five from that
solution so i guess the conclusion is
think about this geometrically you know
whenever you see
all of these symbols translating them
into their visual meaning is
always going to be a very useful way to
interpret what's happening
and then arrive at the solution much
more quickly than if for example i had
said
prove that the maximum value is equal to
such and such we might have had to have
appealed to something
like calculus but such heavy equipment
is not necessary if what we're trying to
do is just
find the maximum value so more on the
story
complex numbers they're two dimensional
objects do yourself a favor
and draw the shapes that they represent